das ist ein ganz spezieller
krankentransport die patienten die
aussteigen sind urlauber mit einem
positiven corinna test statt nach hause
zu fahren müssen sie jetzt für zehn tage
in quarantäne in ein hotel das alle nur
das krone hotel nennen
268 zimmer sind derzeit belegt
auch ann sophie steinbach aber hier sie
hatte sich beim feiern angesteckt
täglich postete sie videos aus ihrer
isolation
erst habe ich mental breakdown hier zu
sehen war das alles einfach nicht
auszuhalten ist
sie erzählt von fehlendem klopapier
essen das nicht schmeckt und von einer
sternstunde
wo ich bin so glücklich gerade ich werde
das jetzt mit euch am boxen meinen
überlebenspaket davon werde ich mich
komplett hier ernähren die nächsten tage
braucht wie im himmel wie im himmel
ann sophie ist jetzt wieder gesund und
in deutschland wir treffen sie zu hause
ihre videos sagt sie hätten einen
austausch mit den anderen
leidensgenossinnen im hotel ermöglicht
und ich haben sehr viele angeschrieben
nach meinen tecdax ja wir haben gesehen
dass du auch da bist wie geht's dir oder
was weißt du irgendwas genaueres weil
die genau das gleiche problem hatten wir
man wusste nicht kriegst du jetzt an
genesen und scheint wann kommst du aus
wie ist das mit dem testen keiner hat
irgendwelche antworten bekommen urlaub
auf mallorca das risiko fliegt mit viele
kommen um am ballermann zu feiern
jeden abend party ohne abstand ohne
maske
es sind vor allem die jüngeren die sich
anstecken
trotzdem macht sich kaum einer sorgen
über gucken das risiko besteht immer
aber wir testen soll täglich wir haben
selber schnelltests mitgenommen und
selber morgens zu testen und so weiter
lässt neue leute kennen hat trotzdem
spaß
die sieben tage incidents auf mallorca
ist hoch zu hoch sie liegt bei 388 der
sommer hotspot der deutschen ist jetzt
hoch risikogebiet wer nicht geimpft oder
genesen ist muss nach der heimkehr in
quarantäne
die urlauber mit denen wir sprachen
nehmen das eher gelassen
die meisten sind geimpft manch einer
macht sogar ein motto daraus haben auch
lange überlegt ob wir den urlaub
trainieren sollen aber damit sind doch
dazu entschlossen wenn man ein bisschen
vorsichtig ist eigentlich kann man da
den ganzen
ja der incident so ein bisschen aus dem
weg gehen auch und muss es ja jetzt
nicht so auf die spitze treiben und dann
irgendwelche flugs die tourismusbranche
ist dennoch alarmiert die hotel belegung
liegt bei maximal 70 prozent oft ist sie
deutlich niedriger
die große sorge deutsche gäste könnten
ausbleiben
dabei seien 57 prozent der inselbewohner
bereits geimpft und die situation in den
krankenhäusern entspannt diese
entscheidung wurde ganz klar auf der
grundlage der hohen inzidenz getroffen
wir aber glauben dass man eine viel
breitere bewertung haben muss es sollten
auch andere faktoren berücksichtigt
werden wie zum beispiel die situation in
den krankenhäusern
wir sind in achter im osten mallorcas
eine kleine stadt im hinterland hügel
statt mehr
hier ist die korona dichte nicht so hoch
wie in der hauptstadt
und hier hat christophorus häuschen sein
kleines boutiquehotel alle acht zimmer
sind ausgebucht
ich bin im moment auch noch optimistisch
ich weiß aber wir brauchen immer im
sommer ein polster um durch den winter
zu kommen wenn es jetzt so läuft wie es
jetzt läuft werden was schaffen wenn es
noch größere einbrüche gibt dann dann
wird's eng
einbrüche könnte es geben durch die
einstufung als hochrisiko gebiet schon
jetzt sagt der hotelier lebe er von
einem tag auf den anderen
ich sage allen meinen leuten die ich
jetzt neu an stelle ich verspreche euch
nichts
es kann sein dass morgen alles wieder
vorbei ist corona gibt den rhythmus vor
auf mallorca auch in cala d'or
normalerweise tummeln sich in der bucht
30.000 sommergäste jetzt sind es
deutlich weniger
das merken vor allem die geschäfte und
restaurants die saison wird kürzer als
wir gedacht haben
es wird ein kampf weil wir ausgaben
haben die wir nicht decken
der nächste winter wird für uns alle
hier sehr schwer
die angst vor jobverlust vor insolvenz
bleibt es wäre dann der zweite
verkorkste corona sommer fast alle
hängen vom tourismus ab mit einer
gehörigen portion angst im bauch hatte
im märz auch die familie tanner hotel
wiedereröffnet aber die gäste kamen und
kommen auch jetzt im juli immer noch wie
dieses mal
eigentlich ein grund zur freude wäre da
nicht die neue krone lage denn kinder ab
sechs müssen nach dem urlaub in
deutschland in quarantäne
wir haben bisher familien mit kleinen
kindern gehabt und unser familienzimmer
was wir haben ist bisher nicht belegt es
ist ein uhr 15 nachts am ballermann
einsatzbesprechung der polizei zwei
gehen am strand entlang sagt der beamte
mit maske und drei oben am morgen krank
eigentlich dürften um diese zeit nur
noch personen aus einem gemeinsamen
haushalt auf der straße sein
das sind die neuen regeln in corona
einzudämmen regeln an die sich keiner
hält die operation räumung der
strandpromenade beginnt die meisten
weichen friedlich aber nicht jeder will
gehen es gibt kleinere gerangel
es dauert keine 20 minuten dann ist die
aktion beendet
nur noch die kehrmaschine räumt die
überreste der partie weg bis morgen dann
sind alle wieder da genauso wie das
risiko corona ann-sophie steinbacher
übrigens würde wieder nach mallorca
fahren aber auf keinen fall mehr zum
ballermann
das sagt sie sei einfach leichtsinnig
gewesen